[Music]
the first time like I laid down the
guitar track and then play the fiddle on
top of this and make me have goose-bumpy
shamanic
[Music]
my name's nature gong-gong burger I am a
musician marina from China but I have a
Mongolian ancestry
so this our Mongolian fiddle we call
that money [ __ ] or in the English we
can say horse hat fiddle
throat singing is a very ancient and
traditional way of singing you press
your throat and you you generate one a
sound but then you generate an over tune
on the top of the within your mouth oh
it sounds like it sounds like to sound
at the same time
[Music]
if you read the Mongolian history it's
all about those brave warrior conquer
all around the world and they don't fear
death you know that kind of spirit
mento people heavy-metal people it's
also like you know very manly you don't
give a [ __ ] you just do whatever you
want you know like this free free
experience definitely free experience
people will say Oh while you are doing
Mongolian music they don't understand
the whole ancestry thing they don't
understand your own culture identity but
at the end of day I love the Mongolian
culture and that's all what it matters
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
homey - us our obstacle new gentlemen
Lothos team a master who artists
mahavihara scheming they're also hosting
Hajime item in this him highest
authority in our mattress in your notice
as Mongoose Mongolia stunned in distant
action would sing in order with hungry
horn and in dark path Virginia register
[Music]
sorry don't wanna kill innocent
dr. stone a missed call impacts college
this is first has no team in general to
build up heroin detectors before
possible workers are too hot your report
on auto-ship humid then Denmark
Osawatomie they had she read concerned
this gesture of shadows chatter - walls
customer and take homie knows we need
for make me horny of ice technique
meaning of the us- do come on give it a
secret
although cerulean after cheating on me
so logic it's just empty and mana diode
which has launched it all these know how
I like teacher even
Murata faster part worst ham embodiment
and sander data coming in Tom servo
children hostage and salmon see Joe
wheel touches it Camilla talks to us man
in cinnabar it's incurable
thought oh gosh - oh me oh Moo a tremor
a odd Masterton burger patties and ma
the robots kaku booties diameter toes
madam chairman ma you know what II
suppose under
[Music]
[Applause]
until Whitney said who me talk Lord
homido the ads industry moon yeah I'm
gonna need a better home I said
[Music]
a mystery squad the engineers matalava
s test chatter holy militant not ashamed
he I mean intervals are tender but
cumbersome she's worth you're in our
water hissing she's meeting J out her
mission at home in the water so in this
we had a dispute in the sub channel
which or a magician Amsterdam
[Music]
for thousands of years the duck of
people have lived in the northernmost
part of Mongolia we're breeding reindeer
is a way of life today though the last
nomadic reindeer herders in the world
that Amanda Haruka Hana Nolan Columbian
mingle interpreter samehada's purchased
a wicked in tamil medical administration
[Music]
the technology with weak position last
June dragon who you are whateve tamil
agenda money guru locker room we are at
homology single target and it soon in
mongolian folklore reindeer or mystical
creatures believed to carry the spirit
of past loved ones but most Mongolians
have never come face to face with one
the animals prefer region most people
would find uninhabitable
little harder a hotel college annuity
lunation $18 some heavy chart average
annuity
little harder on a mission Nick jr.
artistry militia girls over to me let
him divide despite the harsh conditions
these herders mainly rely on their
reindeer for milk and transport and take
pride in raising them Tom Allah Jalla WA
noodle heartening that she forgot to say
I'm ready but that's on a table every
life
[Music]
wanna do not on the car my room and Tom
on vellum destroy the nominative on
machine marks are not Auto watching the
Lancers Jason Takata social note our car
on human child every Jew and
Iannetta luminous deterrent that time on
the towel will chew away your job
we host or another no Harriet Everest we
are gonna pin the NASA wore a helmet
[Music]
every time I take my Eagle out I get
butterflies in my stomach it's this
dichotomy between a heavy bird on your
fist that just instantly becomes lighter
than air you get to cultivate a really
unique relationship there very few
people flying eagles in the United
States and of that only a handful of
women but my very good friend Jamaica is
beginning her journey into Eagle
falconry
the ability to be mentored by a woman I
thought that that was something unique
that I shouldn't pass up that
opportunity
[Music]
Falconeri is the ancient art and
tradition of using a trained bird of
prey to hunt its natural quarry in the
wild I spend a lot of time in Mongolia
apprentices under kazakh Eagle hunters
when I started I felt pretty out of
place because I didn't have that hunting
experience and I was a girl it made me
really fortify my passion and persevere
because it was hard in the beginning
I've admired her from the very beginning
her journey into falconry was different
than most the gumption she had as a
teenager to go to Mongolia and learn
about Eagle falconry that's a rare thing
a little over a year ago I got a call
from a friend who had found an eagle
standing in the road about a mile from
my house it was close to death so I took
it to the vet that afternoon and
participated in in rescuing that Eagle
falconry is pretty much the only way at
this point and we know for sure allows
that eagle a reasonable chance at
survival by helping them through that
period where they're learning how to
catch things I made it my life's mission
to get an eagle permit and acquire an
eagle through an established rehab
program that works with falconers
there's a lot of knowledge involved in
falconry there's also a lot of ways to
do it wrong it's really not necessarily
instinctive I would not want to get into
Eagle falconry without a good mentor to
contact knowing that Lauren was
available to be a mentor to me was
a huge part of being willing to make
that decision to get inside the mind of
an eagle the first time is a it can be a
difficult experience you just have to
find your bearings and understand where
an eagle is coming from in order to
create a good fit confident hunting
Eagle so essentially that's what I'm
helping Jamaica do when you find someone
that has that passion and is willing to
share it with you it's is really a
special thing the bond that you develop
with someone who gives a view their time
the way that Lauren is giving to me and
will be something I'll treasure forever
and hopefully someday I'll pass that on
to somebody else